- Hi, I'm Amber Jay and we're here
at BuzzFeed Motion Pictures
where people come from
across the country and, even
around the world, to work.
And they all got their start somewhere
so I'm gonna go around the office and ask,
what was your first job?
- My first job ...
- My very first job ...
- My first job was working at the Gap.
(crickets chirping)
No one laughed.
Okay, good, I feel good.
- I opened my own lemonade
stand when I was 12
and I hired my brother and
my neighbors to work for me.
- My parents were like,
you're gonna get a job at 14.
- It was like a bookshop and cafe.
15, I got a job doing that.
Just making pizza, bagels and lattes.
- 16 and I worked at McDonald's.
- I was a cashier at a Chinese restaurant.
- I worked for nuns and
I did their marketing.
- Bath and Body Works.
- Camp counselor.
- I sold knives for Cutco.
- A summer internship at a tech company.
- I was a host at Joe's Crab Shack.
So I answered the phone, I
took people to their tables
and I cleaned up the
bathroom of a Crab Shack.
- You have to pick up all the popcorn,
you have to sweep everything up.
- Clean up the cafeteria
and all the hallways
and the dorms and vacuum
and do stuff like that.
It was a shitty job and I hated it.
- Assistant pet groomer.
- Being a PA on set, I
had to pick up dog poop
for a good couple weeks before I got paid.
- Acting as an extra on a movie.
- It was at a Korean
entertainment company.
I started as an intern there.
I made a lot of coffee.
(laughs)
- I was making sandwiches
and now I can make
a really good sandwich, not
just because I'm a woman.
- I used to answer the phone like this,
welcome to ANA hardware where we put
the word, hard, in hardware.
(laughs)
No lie, my boss was like, you
gotta cut that (bleep) out.
My philosophy in life
is just take each day
one step at a time and just
don't worry about the future.
- You should be able to find some amount
of happiness in what you're doing.
- Don't think something's
out of reach or unattainable.
- If you're pursuing an artistic career,
I think jobs are for quitting
and your career is your art.
- You never know what opportunity
leads to your next one.
So, it might seem like a shitty job,
but doing that shitty job might help you
meet a really cool person that
helps you get a better job.
- Get this paper.
- Whatever you do, you do your best.
Don't half-ass anything,
that's what I would say.
If you gonna clean toilets, you gonna be
the best toilet cleaner ever.